Más que esto,
es una historia que necesitábamos escuchar cuando éramos más jóvenes.
Dada la naturaleza de nuestra historia,
conozco las palabras que la acompañan --
víctima, violador --
y las etiquetas son maneras de organizar conceptos,
pero también pueden ser deshumanizantes en sus connotaciones.
Cuando alguien se convierte en víctima,
es muy fácil catalogarla como dañada,
deshonrada,
menos que eso.
De la misma forma, cuando a alguien se le etiqueta como violador,
es muy fácil llamarle monstruo --
inhumano.
¿Pero cómo podemos entender qué es lo que en la sociedad
causa violencia
si nos negamos a reconocer la humanidad de quien lo comete?
(Aplausos)
¿Cómo empoderar a los sobrevivientes si los hacemos sentir menos?
¿Cómo discutir soluciones para una de las mayores amenazas
en la vida de las mujeres y niños en el mundo,
si las palabras que usamos son parte del problema?
TS: Aprendí,
que mis acciones aquella noche de 1996 fueron egocéntricas.
Sentí merecer el cuerpo de Thordis.
Tuve influencias sociales positivas
y ejemplos de similar conducta a mi alrededor.
Pero en aquella ocasión,
escogí las influencias negativas.
Las que dicen que las mujeres tienen un valor menor,
y que los hombres tienen cierto poder sobre los cuerpos de ellas.
Sin embargo, estas influencias son externas a mí.
Solamente fui yo en ese cuarto el que tomó las decisiones,
nadie más.
Cuando te apropias de algo
y reconoces tu culpa,
creo que algo sorprendente puede pasar.
Es lo que llamo la paradoja de la apropiación.
Pensé que me doblaría bajo el peso de la responsabilidad.
Que mi certificado de humanidad sería quemado.
En vez, tuve la oportunidad de apropiarme de lo que hice,
me di cuenta de que aquello no representaba todo lo que yo soy.
En pocas palabras,
algo que hiciste no tiene que constituir la suma de lo que eres.
El ruido en mi cabeza disminuyó.
La autocompasión tenía hambre de oxígeno,
y fue reemplazada con el limpio aire de la aceptación --
la aceptación de que le hice daño a esta increíble persona a mi lado;
la aceptación de que soy parte de un grupo de hombres que crece cada día
los cuales han sido sexualmente violentos con sus parejas.
No subestimen el poder de las palabras.
Decirle a Thordis que la violé cambió mi armonía conmigo mismo,
y también con ella.
Más importante que esto,
la culpa se transfirió de Thordis a mí.
Muy a menudo,
la responsabilidad se le atribuye
a las sobrevivientes de la violencia sexual,
y no a los hombres que la cometen.
Muy a menudo,
negar y huir aleja a todos de la realidad.
Definitivamente hay un diálogo público ocurriendo en este momento
y, como a mucha gente,
nos conmueve que haya menos rechazo
de esta difícil pero importante discusión.
Siento una real responsabilidad de contribuir con nuestras voces.
TE: Lo que hicimos no es una fórmula que le prescribamos a otros.
Nadie tiene el derecho de decirle a alguien cómo manejar su dolor
o sus mayores errores.
Romper con el silencio nunca es fácil,
y dependiendo de dónde estés en el mundo,
puede ser mortal hablar sobre violación.
Sé que hasta el más traumático evento de mi vida
es un testamento de mi privilegio,
pues puedo hablar sobre él sin ser condenada al ostracismo,
o ser asesinada.
Pero con el privilegio de tener una voz
viene la responsabilidad de usarla.
Es lo que le debo a las sobrevivientes que no pueden.
La historia que contamos es única,
pero tan común siendo la violencia sexual una pandemia global.
Pero no tiene que ser así.
Algo que resultó ser útil en mi proprio viaje de curación
es educarme sobre la violencia sexual.
Como resultado, he leído, he escrito
y charlado sobre este problema por más de una década,
participando en conferencias alrededor del mundo.
En mi experiencia,
los que asisten a esos eventos son casi exclusivamente mujeres.
Es tiempo de que dejemos de tratar la violencia sexual
como un problema femenino.
(Aplausos)
La mayoría de la violencia sexual contra las mujeres y los hombres
es realizadas por hombres.
Y aun sus voces están poco representadas en esta discusión.
Se necesita que todos estemos aquí.
Imaginen todo el sufrimiento que podríamos aliviar
si nos atreviéramos a enfrentar esto juntos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)